this is howard jacobson jacobson runs a
pharmacy in long island new york
a common drug jacobson and other
pharmacies sell is called metformin
a cheap drug that's used for type 2
diabetes
type 2 adult onset diabetes the drug
itself only costs jacobson a dollar 61.
if the patient paid in cash out of
pocket for the drug jacobson would sell
it to them for four dollars earning him
a respectable 2.39 cents in profits
the patient gets their medicine at a
reasonable price the pharmacy gets their
cut the drug maker gets their cut and
everyone is happy
but in this particular case the patient
paid with their insurance plan
all of a sudden the patient had to pay
10 and 84 cents for the drug instead of
four dollars over double the price
and even with the higher price jacobs
and the pharmacist ends up making only a
dollar ninety three in profit
instead of the two dollars and thirty
nine cents he would have made if the
patient paid cash
higher costs for the patient lower
profit for the pharmacy and the rest of
the money
that whopping seven dollars and thirty
cents goes to the insurance company and
their middlemen and you want to know
what the best part is
it's that jacobson's customer didn't
even know he was getting played
now following common sense jacobson
should just tell his customers to pay
cash to avoid getting scammed by their
insurance company in these situations
but until recently he couldn't because
he was under contract with these
insurance companies and their middlemen
to not let customers in on the secret
unless they
asked you could have sold it to them for
four dollars instead they paid a 10.84
copay right but until recently jacobson
couldn't bring this up
unless the customer asked he says that's
because many of his contracts with the
pbms
contain provisions that prohibited him
from pointing out
that they could get their prescription
cheaper if they didn't go through their
insurance plan pharmacists call them
gag clauses now at this scale paying ten
dollars versus four dollars is
not that big of a deal for most people
but when you get to drugs for terminal
diseases or rare diseases
where this amount of drugs would cost
u.s consumers around 3 million dollars
these markups can start getting rather
deadly
the sticker price for revlimid has more
than doubled in the last decade
today a single month's supply of 28
pills
can cost as much as 22 000
if this isn't making much sense to you
good that's because it shouldn't
that is the beauty of the wonderful
industry that is big pharma
a very lucrative racket now it's not so
lucrative for the patients or the
pharmacies or even the drug makers at
times who people usually like to point
the finger at
no the real winners in this racket are
the insurance companies and their
middlemen
and just like any racket to understand
how it works we have to follow the money
[Music]
to understand the rules we just
witnessed here we have to learn a little
bit about the supply chain of big pharma
now typically supply chains for your
average products are pretty simple
manufacturers sell their products to
retailers consumers buy those products
from retailers at a higher price
that way retailers make some profit to
keep for themselves and they get to buy
more products from the manufacturers
the big pharma supply chain is a little
bit more complicated
okay it's a lot more complicated and it
all starts with the drug companies
big pharma companies spend billions to
develop drugs and to try to get them to
pass the fda
with the average cost to bring a drug to
market being anywhere from 1 billion to
2.6 billion dollars
then they have places like china or
india produce these drugs for dirt cheap
and from there they set the list price
for the drug the raw price if you bought
it straight from the manufacturer
but i think it's important that people
understand that the chemicals themselves
cost almost nothing and this is the
first reason why drugs can get so
expensive
the fda has a ton of regulations drug
companies need to make a profit in order
to incentivize them to keep making drugs
i think profits are a great thing to
stain uh
your corporate existence but not only
that they have to recoup the cost of
their research and to fund more research
for more drugs
no matter what the demand for a drug is
it still costs billions to make
so if companies spend billions to make a
life-saving drug that only a few
thousand people need per year
the cost of that single pill is going to
go dramatically up imagine for a moment
popping a pill before bed that costs
about 13.50
now imagine waking up the next morning
find that the price of the exact same
pill jumped to 750
overnight that is just what happened to
one drug turing is a very small company
it's a new company
and we're not a profitable company so
for us to try to exist and maintain a
profit i think is pretty reasonable
can drug companies price gouge for the
sake of making a quick buck on the most
desperate of people
of course do they intentionally do this
probably
but they are doing all the work so it's
a little bit more understandable
but if we stopped here it still wouldn't
give us a clear picture so let's move on
to the next step in the supply chain
from there wholesalers transport the
drugs and sell them to pharmacies
this is where the patient comes in the
patient gets prescribed medication from
their doctor
the patient then goes to the pharmacy to
get their meds however
most patients have health insurance to
save money on big medical expenses
and most use their insurance to pay for
their meds because in their mind they
think that by using insurance they're
automatically going to save more money
so the patient pays for a portion of the
meds to their pharmacy which is called
their copay or out-of-pocket cost
and for the remainder of the cost the
pharmacy sends a bill to their insurance
company
the patient feels as if they're getting
their money's worth from their insurance
keyword feels but this is where things
get messy
just like any business insurance
companies are in the business of making
money not giving away free charity
nothing wrong with that but in this case
it creates a perverse incentive
patients pay their monthly bill for
insurance and when medical bills arise
in a perfect world the patient would pay
the entire bill themselves and the
insurance companies would just sit back
and collect that monthly bill
but this isn't a perfect world and if
you the insurance company don't make the
patient feel as if you're covering the
majority of their medical costs
what is the point of them being your
customer but the more of their medical
bills you cover
the less profit you make so we have to
recoup that money somewhere
enter rebates if we have to keep our
insurance customers happy by covering a
higher percentage of their costs
why not go to the drug makers and say
hey all your customers depend on us the
insurance companies for them to be able
to afford your products
or in other words we're the gatekeepers
to your customers
so if you want us to cover more of the
cost of your drugs so patients can
actually buy your drugs
you better give us some money in return
with the underlying message being
bribe us and that's what the drug
companies are forced to do
for nearly every drug patients buy at
the pharmacy counter with their
insurance the drug company pays a
commission back to the insurance company
of course we don't call it a commission
or a bribe because the public would be
outraged
just like how we don't call stimulus
checks welfare no we call these
commissions
rebates another issue that we've been
hearing a lot about that the president
has even been talking about is something
called
rebates that sounds like a good thing so
it certainly does
sound like a good thing rebate is money
back it could lower price for the
consumers
the problem is that in this opaque world
where we have no idea what these
contracts say
rebates actually can increase price and
the people responsible for negotiating
how big of a commission i mean rebate
the insurance companies get
that responsibility falls onto the
broker
brokers are those middlemen that
negotiate with drug makers to get as
much money back to the insurance
companies as possible
since the insurance companies want to
incentivize those brokers to get as much
money back as possible
it's safe to assume that these brokers
pocket a cut of every rebates
now if you're wondering do they really
just flat out call these people brokers
now you're catching on to the game of
course they don't these brokers go by
the very inconspicuous title of pharmacy
benefit managers or pbms
for many of the drugs a pharmaceutical
company sells it pays a rebate
to the pbm the pbm sometimes
pockets a portion of the rebate and
passes another portion onto the
insurance company or
employer and to squeeze even more money
out of drug makers we the insurance
companies have one more trick
up our sleeves humans work off of
incentives
so if you want bigger rebates from drug
companies give them an incentive to do
that
so if you give us a bigger rebate we'll
cover a bigger portion of the cost of
the drug to our patients
if we cover say 90 of the cost of your
drug the product is going to be
perceived to be cheaper in the eyes of
our patients
so you're probably going to get more
sales this is what's called moving up
the formulary
the highest tier in the formulary is the
lowest copay for the patient
and the lowest tier is the highest copay
for the patient
when the pharmaceutical company pays a
higher rebate
the pbm will move the drug up on the
formulary
now there's nothing wrong with
commissions or rebates or sales people
but in this case like we mentioned
earlier whether you agree with it or not
drug companies need to make a profit in
order to stay in business and to keep
innovating
and when they get squeezed from these
rebates what did they do they raised the
price of the drugs to make up for it
azar a former pharmaceutical executive
also said he's heard reports of pbm's
threatening drug makers we've had
several drug companies come
in who are want to execute substantial
material reductions in their drug prices
they're finding hurdles from pharmacy
benefit managers and distributors where
they might say well if you
decrease your list price i will take you
off formulary
compared to your competitor who will
have a higher list price where i will
make more money i find that
unconscionable
and who takes a burden of that higher
price that's right
the patience let's take a look at a
simple example
let's say a drug costs ten dollars for a
drug maker to turn out and they sell it
for a hundred dollars
to keep it simple let's just assume
that's also the price the pharmacy sells
it for
so for the drug maker the list price is
a hundred dollars the cost is ten
dollars so their profit is ninety
dollars
the patient doesn't wanna pay a hundred
dollars so they use their insurance
the insurance company also wants to keep
as much money as possible
so they have their pbm or broker
negotiate a rebate of fifty dollars from
the drug maker
ten dollars of that fifty dollars goes
to the broker and forty dollars of that
rebate goes to the insurance company
the insurance company uses that forty
dollars to cover forty dollars of the
patients a hundred dollar bill
so the patient pays only sixty dollars
out of pocket so now the drug maker is
only making forty dollars instead of
ninety dollars
after the rebate of fifty dollars a
forty dollar profit happens to not be
enough to recoup the research costs fund
new drugs so the drug maker raises the
list price by fifty dollars to make up
for the rebates
now the drug maker is back to square one
with a profit of 90
the list price went up to 150 the cost
to manufacture the drug is still at 10
the rebate they pace attracts another 50
so the profit is back up to 90
the insurance company is still only
getting a 50 rebate even with the price
hike
so when the patient returns for a refill
the price went up to 150 dollars
their insurance is still covering only
40 dollars after paying 10 dollars to
their broker
now they're left with a bill of 110 and
what started out as patients not wanting
to pay a hundred dollars out of pocket
those same patients end up paying a
higher price for the exact same product
if they would have just paid in cash
by increasing the price of the drug the
manufacturer has more leeway
to give a big rebate to the pbm the pbm
is happy
the drug is covered on the formulary
unfortunately for all of us
drug prices go up and the best part
they're saying to themselves hey
my insurance company is paying a portion
of this drug for me i'm saving money
and no one is the wiser
now it's easy to blame drug companies
it's easy to blame insurance companies
and their pharmacy benefit managers like
we've been doing this entire video
but this is just what happens when the
customer is taken out of the buying
process
let's say you go to dinner with a few
friends one night you guys get separate
checks
whatever you order you pay for on a
separate night you guys split the check
evenly
in which case do you think you guys will
order more this is the very same test
college economics departments like to
run
and without fail when you split the
check evenly everyone orders more
after all why not why not an extra glass
of wine why not an extra appetizer
you're only paying for a fraction of the
cost
the result everyone gets stuck with a
higher bill
welcome to healthcare when your
insurance covers 85
of your bill you don't care how much
things cost you don't shop around to see
who offers the cheapest blood tests the
cheapest mri scan the cheapest drugs
we consume without thinking because
someone else pays
by insuring so much of our health care
we ensure that we are blind to the cost
of the very thing we were trying to save
money on
mixing the other incentives of drug
companies insurance companies and
middlemen like we talked about and the
price for things like big pharma drugs
and everything else
skyrockets so what's the solution to
solve this mess
i have no idea what i do know is that
the best way to protect yourself from
things like rising healthcare prices
shady insurance companies
is to simply make more money finish this
phrase for me
money is the root of all what
that's right evil that is how a lot of
people view money
yet money solves a lot of problems in
life including ever increasing cost of
living so you shouldn't feel ashamed to
go after it
and one of the more realistic routes to
go about making more money
getting a remote job think about it
you're not limited by the jobs you have
around your area you don't have to start
a business from scratch
companies have now started taking remote
jobs a lot more seriously you learn a
valuable skill that you can take with
you for the rest of your life
coding digital marketing or what have
you and you can use it as a jumping off
point to do whatever you want
saving up for emergencies like 2020
traveling the world as a digital nomad
or starting a business
the last point is exactly what i did i
landed a 40
per hour remote web dev job when i was
19 which gave me the time and money to
do what i'm doing right now
so if you want to get a remote job check
out a course i offer where i break down
everything what kind of remote job you
should go after how to best learn it
resumes applying interviews the whole
nine yards
take alex for example his digital
marketing business had to close because
2020
so he used the course to land a 25
remote digital marketing job in just 19
days
and what is more is that i live in south
africa and the nice thing about living
in south africa with the
american job is that i get paid in
dollars and dollars have a lot of buying
power in south africa
25 dollars an hour for me here would be
the same as
75 an hour for the average american
albeit he was already skilled in digital
marketing but you get the point
are you guaranteed to land a remote job
with this program no
you still have to work your butt off
like me and everyone else but what you
do get is a very solid foundation
that i wish i would have had so click
the link below and sign up today for a
very reasonable price while also
supporting videos like this
at the same time
big pharma was by far one of the most
requested hit lists that i should get on
when i asked you guys what hit list i
should get on next on instagram
so here we are if you guys want more big
farmer videos just let me know in the
comments below as always because this
definitely barely
scratched the surface on the big pharma
industry
if you guys want to participate in this
sort of thing in the future you can
follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io and you will play a direct
role in helping me not be a pleb anymore
by getting me up to 10k followers
if you are new to this channel and
you're not subscribed what are you doing
because we make video essays just like
this one every single week for
absolutely free
and all you have to do is click the
subscribe button and turn on that
notification bell
and if you want email notifications just
in case like something whatever happened
to this channel you can sign up for
email notifications for when new videos
come out
with the link in the video description
but that is gonna wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
absolutely